[Music]
so if you don't know here's what the
show it's just a bunch of funny people
telling like 100% true stories doing
great kids you don't know what's gonna
happen
hi I'm Ari Shaffir I'm the host that
this is not happening me and my friend
Eric we were just sitting around a
Thanksgiving party and we're just on
mushroom stories to each other you know
which I was telling his story I ended up
using later on the show maybe I didn't
pee myself at all but then I was like
wait what if I peed so much the entire
thing is just one big piece day it will
meet some story before tell us some guys
some bouncer like him a hard time that
he saw his pupils were like that wide
and I was like dude everybody's got
mushroom stories a lot of people decide
to do mushrooms for the first time in
the woods maybe at a great Phish concert
I thought why don't I do it in the most
nightmarish landscape possible so I just
eat some mushrooms and then I'm like
well never had mushrooms before I might
as well throw a couple percocet on top
of it book in the side room at the
improv a little 40 seat room and I was
like let me just do a show you have 12
people come in the audience it was fun
as and we did one other one like a
month later we did when it's all about
sex stories and then we were like let's
just keep going and then we just started
doing different topics so I would
forward that way hey guys I think the
storytelling show on Thursday come out
the improv got mad at me once and they
were like why why are you guys having
Bilborough and Jim Jefferies in a side
room like I don't know that's the room
we go hey that's sort of I supposed to
not fill it up every show in LA and New
York and Chicago everywhere really they
all the name I don't know why they can't
just be like comedy night on Thursday so
we're like oh yeah I guess we sent it on
some some French painter he had some
painting of a pipe and underneath it
says this is not a pipe in French it's
supposed to be some commentary on how
art is is a thing but it's also not a
thing it's not a real type that's there
just a picture of a pipe I kind of a
play on like these stories are not
really happening right now and also on a
second level but this is not happening
because some of the stuff is so crazy
her pressure is fighting a bear I fought
a bear one time
I know it sounds as ridiculous to me as
it does to you or always said he has to
like get away from a prison riot so I
get back to my cell I say hey you
Mexican what miss don't boost me you say
that mean we gonna ride we're gonna stab
a couple of black guys up that's the
kind of stuff like this is not happening
but then it's like well it is it did and
here's what went on this is a part of my
12-step program go to a strip club and
tell the story it's weird but that's the
first step but it is penis is much like
hell yes you can come down and
fundraising story show here
being a strip club really helps you like
relax into whatever they're
gonna say you know over your mom or
dad you know on drugs or anything you're
gonna say it's not gonna be like how
dare you moments but I've asked comics
before like do you have a story you have
any stories they go no and then I go
well we're having a road trip story
topic oh no I do have a story about
Rochat cities focus for them and they've
helped some thing so sometimes that
rehearsals are not rehearsal it's the
first time anybody's ever said that
story it was great it's great saying to
different people like Stanhope having
really dark filthy lines and some like
really degenerate feelings did you
them I just cornered her just Saturday
did you him and she said no but
then she continued on with but I gave
him a blowjob in his car as a Sal
Vulcano was a really genuinely nice
person you know right right in a subject
I have your pants
and I'm about to tell her you know just
drop me a line I can get into you you
know but then I thought wouldn't it be
great if I wrote her a ransom note for
them and seeing them both come to like
like topics in a different way
Comedy Central said you want to do some
of these on the web sure you know we've
kept doing them digitally what a bizarre
the paramedic wanted to tell me the
worst news in the least amount of words
possible we like these I'm like come on
TV like yeah I mean whatever Matt we're
doing I'm so like so like where wants to
get involved we've got Jeff Tomczyk to
come down and director for us he was
really cool I had this crazy cool
opening
[Music]
and this year for season 3 is gonna be
all deaths so everyone is a different
way that I die we have some great
stories of season 3 Regan I was pretty
excited about just getting with you a
campaign manager for a dog remember Bud
Light had
spuds Mackenzie yeah well I wasn't
qualified to be his campaign manager
it's all the details in how you tell him
over like what specifically happened
Louie innocence in it sir yeah my dad
yeah we're the FBI
yes so that's a cool thing too you see
all these people it kind of equalized
everybody all these stories so like
whatever level of fame they have or
success they have but it's like they
were all children at some point or
they're all trying to make it you know
they're all in 19 or 20 getting into
trouble somewhere it's interesting to
have a non comedian you know coming with
the community so we got Henry Rollins
last year he killed
I'm unnerving ly polite but I'm also
capably violent and wk he did greatness
here I wanted to be a fashion designer
in case you didn't get that impression
already catch a god when you catch a
comic doing like really in the zone I
being completely real
yeah you just get locked in with them
you can get sad in places you can get
happy and get stupid but everyone's just
in there just listening because you just
get invested but it's gotta be real it's
gotta be genuine completely genuine you
guys that's a show do you have a good
time
[Applause]
[Music]